wunderschönen guten tag willkommen zu
blocken ist arg nummer vier ich starte
den heutigen tag mit einer kleinen
darbietung der kommentare die ich gerade
teilweise lesen musste erstmal danke für
die ganzen lieben kommentare und für die
schönen weihnachtlichen anregungen
stimmungen und ein fall fürs liebe
verbreiten das finde ich sehr toll und
ich bin auch eigentlich nicht ein fan
davon dass man negative kommentare so
hervorhebt und irgendwie immer nur auf
die eingeht weil das ego verletzt ist
und man sich rechtfertigen möchte ich
finde sowieso das buch habe ich hier
nicht mehr aber seit ich die viel
versprechen gelesen habe bin ich auch
mal auf einen ganz anderen trip ich
nehme nichts mehr persönlich deswegen
möchte ich die kommentare von den herren
warum sind sie meine herren das ist was
es mit den los spielen ja schön dass
manni einkassieren genau jeden tag ein
video machen
nervenaufreibend das manchmal sein kann
dass du deinen job machst und leute sich
darüber beschweren dass du deinen job
machst chef ich möchte mein
weihnachtsgeld nicht haben denn das ist
extra money und ich will nicht für meine
arbeit bezahlt werden
lassen sie es also im dezember laufen
die monetarisierung gerade sehr gut
deswegen könnt ihr viel hochladen
niemann nehmen niemand dass wir ihrem
los dass wir ihren los sehe ich bin hier
nicht um geld zu verdienen das ist
ehrenamt youtuber sein ist ein ehrenamt
dieser rage ist jetzt vorbei ich wollte
das nur einmal sagen es ist so komisch
oder
also vor allem schauen die leute meine
videos schauen sie nicht angeben sie
einfach wie es bei youtube ein und jeder
der irgendwie daily dezember hoch lädt
bekommt dann so ein kommentar von denen
ich freue mich dass manchmal an jetzt
starten wir mit positiven vibes denn es
ist die erste beziehung war und wie
unsere erste station machen
ich freue mich ich freue mich ich
brauche aber einen zock merke ich gerade
mal vier gewundert warum ich aussehe wie
eine yogalehrerin ich werde heute noch
yoga machen
[Musik]
es ist ein cache einheiten superheld
jetzt sicher die bude aus mein lieblings
champagner
ja klar er habe schon so viel
ausprobiert muss auch mal sagen also
mein lieblings champagners meine pink
champagne weil das der erste champagner
war die nicht getrunken habe und mir
sehr gut geschmeckt hat seitdem schon
bei news bin jetzt keine champagner
kennerin nur dass er nicht denkt dass
das blog müssen money mich zu abgehoben
gemacht hat hat man diese leute mir vor
ihr hatte auf arbeit arbeitskollegen
oder kundenkonten kann auch scheiße sein
ich freue mich gar nicht beschweren und
ich teilweise mitbekomme was leute im
supermarkt oder so von kunden sich
anhören müssen
die scheiße eigentlich warum muss es
denn leute auf dieser welt geben die so
unglaublich frustriert sind und einfach
den rest nerven hauptsache rumreißen in
den kommentaren irgendwelche kassiererin
im supermarkt blöd anmachen
pflegepersonal am besten noch irgendwie
kritisieren weil sie zu schnell arbeiten
oder keine ahnung ich bin grad
verkleidet das kann doch nicht sein das
ist einfach willkommen in meinem haar
styling so macht ihr euch die haare
schön also nach oben muss das sitzen so
abgehoben wie ich mit meinem blog mit
manni ist auch mein kopf bevölkerung
meiner schönsten münsterländer jemand
hatte die idee diesen adventskalender la
nach unten zu packen damit das aussieht
wie das ist der tannenbaum und darunter
die geschenke und ich finde die idee
clip
ich habe gehört dass es schon bei den
leuten geschneit hat eine hoffnung auf
weihnachten ist das ist dieses jahr
schneidet das ist ein richtiges finale
gibt es sehr schön timo können natürlich
machen wir sind leider nicht mehr so gut
[Musik]
trotzdem heute noch können die ja bei
dir ist ja gar nicht so was großes vor
es wird wahrscheinlich so sei nicht die
zeit haben das auch schon gesagt
omeyer ist und dann kommt das hier und
wir haben über den inhalt gesprochen ich
war so mein inhalt ist jetzt nicht so
krassen bisher meiner auch meier ist
wirklich nicht gerade schon gesehen
[Gelächter]
kombiniert und viel zusammen
oh mein gott
dazu laufe jetzt sollte es auch mal
[Musik]
gerade nicht aus übertrieben aufgegangen
aber haben noch ein paar im kühlschrank
ist viel zu schnell oder zu hause machen
ja die anderen haben im kühlschrank
gelebt vapiano stimmt ist überhaupt an
die box
sie sehen diese natürlich funktioneller
aus dass fast belohnt
[Musik]
kann das sein dass sie mir einfach ein
pdf adventskalender gemacht hast
adventskalender werden ausgepackt freue
mich aber auch morgen also wenn dafür
auf diesem level weitergehen muss wenn
man so exotischen enthält hoch gelegt
ihren starken stromschlag start
ich habe ja aber am ende ist wirklich
nicht sein
wenn wir schon mal beim thema aus mein
buch sind dann zeige ich euch mal ganz
kurz was ich gestern abend ausgemalt
haben socks habe ich gestern abend
ausgemalt dann fand ich sehr schön ich
bin meine farbe auswahl ist sehr gut
gelungen und ich muss auch sagen weil
das ist jetzt das winter bruch
erforderlich dass herbst buchen wird
besser mit jeder seite wird man besser
haben ganz viele geschrieben auch wenn
das kann gar nicht ausmalen bei mir
sieht das nicht so schön aus der dritten
seite habe ich richtig gemerkt dass man
so anfängt techniken zu haben und weiß
wie man mehr auf drücken sollte weniger
auf drücken sollte und ich kann euch so
ein haus malbuch recht ans herz legen
weil gerade wenn man schwierigkeiten mit
meditation hat mit mal nicht das handy
in der hand und einfach mal ruhig ohne
vielleicht auch musik kein fernseher
kein nichts sind ausgebucht sagt ein
richtig ein in diese ruhe und
entspannung und man braucht dann
eigentlich nichts anderes so ich weiß
nicht was heute alles passiert aber
wahrscheinlich habe diesem titel gelesen
und freue mich jetzt auf die nächsten
stunden für mich eine überraschung
kategorie run weil der dekorieren
kategorie nicht rekurrieren
die kuriere mein arbeitszimmer
[Musik]
ganz einfach ich ja mein arbeitszimmer
aufgeräumt heute muss es auf jeden fall
geputzt werden also gewischt gesaugt und
so der ganze spaß und dann glaube ich
wird dekoriert darauf habe ich heute
richtig lustig trinken einen kaffee aus
und wir sehen uns beim später wieder was
los
[Musik]
ich hab dir hier vorgesehen die waren
total mega aufgegangen in alle
richtungen und ich hab die produkte sind
wie man es so klebrigen flüssigkeit war
gar nicht habe ich immer versucht leute
es ist stimmt eigentlich noch eine waffe
und mal richtig gut also und falls jetzt
hier pizzabäcker sagen natürlich an den
pizza stein ja dann bringt leider auch
nicht so viele aber besser als grund für
das haben jetzt auch noch gemacht
diesmal für weil wir nur pizza stein
haben und dass er nicht so super heiß
wird haben wir 50 gramm zucker
reingemacht in den damit die das besser
bräunt was die größte was da bei der
zucker karamellisieren
auch hier sehen sie den ersten versuch
von herr timo
[Musik]
aber sie wird immer besser wenn haben
wir langsam kriegen wir diesen hält noch
der teig ist lose zu dicker rand
irgendwie ich gemacht marken pizza das
hat mich richtig aber schon super also
jetzt mal okay erstmal probierst du bist
der macher dieses tor vielleicht
probiert habe hier komplett vergessen
gewürzt wie sollte das wirklich noch gar
nicht gehört
also sie ist halt nicht braun geworden
aber vom look und den luftbläschen aber
die ist so dieser dessen mega luftig und
der ist so geil wenn wir so einen hass
auf die zweite prinzenpaar gucken wie
die zweite wird die neue technik erst
mal nur tomaten sie darauf dass er ein
paar mädchen
das kommt das gute ja okay halt nochmal
[Musik]
ansage ich nehme hier gemacht habe sage
boah dirigiere ich noch mal anders sagen
aber das hat nichts mit ihm zu tun meine
aufgabe bei diesem teamwork projekt
pizza machen ist ausmalen
[Musik]
und unsere ohren auf jeden fall die zeit
nicht an 64 minuten ohne käsereien
korrigiert ist ja wie man sie eigentlich
ein italiener kennen es war deine arbeit
deine haben
oh mein gott oh mein gott
der welt bitter hammer oder ich glaube
von hier aus geht dann auch die werden
das ist es selbst wenn die bekommen
würde wenn eine pizza bestellt wäre das
so lecker danke mir noch mal bestellen
[Musik]
so weit bin ich jetzt gekommen mühselig
und es dauert lange jetzt erst mal ein
mittagsschläfchen
ich habe heute noch einen termin zu
einer wohnungsbesichtigung für meine
freundin und jetzt kann natürlich kein
yoga machen und ich bin heute extrem
früh aufgestanden und habe schon um acht
habe ich halt angefangen zu arbeiten
toll dass man echt so im arsch die ganze
zeit und muße und will einfach nur
schlafen ich sehe sich ein immer dagegen
anzukämpfen und kaffee zu trinken wenn
der körper müde ist dann ist er müde
dann will er schlafen ich habe gerade
mitbekommen dass eine kuh fit für strom
und ich kenne sie von tik tok also ich
habe mir ihre texte also ich verdiene
super lustig ich bin total schockiert
als sie hält noch so jung war und ich
bin ich weiß dass ich wusste schon
vorher dass auch junge leute daran
sterben könnten
ich kann eigentlich verstehen die leute
das nicht ernst nehmen können also ich
will ich will das auch gar nicht hier
ausnutzen oder so ich will halt wirklich
nur sagen bitte tragt eure masken bitte
lasst eure hände bitte haltet abstand zu
den leuten das wollte ich nur kurz
mitnehmen timo ich bin von der
besichtigung zurück ja ich bin von der
besichtigung zurück die besichtigung die
lief sehr gut sie war wirklich sehr
schön war wunderbar tolle ich weiß also
dabei was man items mit timo und dann
ist da ja ich war bei der besichtigung
und es war sehr schön es war eine sehr
tolle wohnung und ich glaube wir haben
sogar eine gute chance dass jemand
anderes für uns bekommt also wir wollen
ja nicht da also wir wollen ich umziehen
wir lieben unsere wohnung aber meine
freundin willi so und jetzt habe ich
gerade timo gefragt
was hab ich dich gefragt ich glaube ich
habe dich und dann habe ich gesagt ich
habe auch uns auf eine schokolade und
dann haben wir alle gesagt ich mache
jetzt mal als erstmal hier ein so wie
viel soll da rein vermischen sie einen
teelöffel will cacau und 1 2 teelöffel
zucker in einer tasse rühren sie die
kakao zucker mischung mit etwas milch
glatt wir nehmen ein bisschen kakao und
dann noch sogar ein bisschen milch rein
und dann hat man die pace um mein gott
es überall verdammte gute heiße
schokolade ja dass man leute ich hab
noch aus der kindheit die aller süß ist
ein weihnachtsessen in unserer dicht
kitschig
hier gibt's die erste tafel war cacau
ganz schwieriger akt
diesmal in der tasse wird sich dann
zeigen seht ihr es ja ich fühle mich
heute nicht zu sehr stressen
das war alles sehr aufregend dass irgend
wenn ich jetzt einmal noch weiter malen
und ihr könnt mir gerne dabei zuschauen
schon habe ich später noch was zu
erzählen wie wie steht unsere chance
heute für viele gipfel also werde ich
mit ihr acht
ich habe bock auf weihnachtsmarkt ok
wird ausgemalt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe sehr lust auf ein stück dieser
pizza würdest du diese witze mit
mitteilen
wir gucken gerade diese circle und das
ist wirklich ganz crazy dieses wie nennt
man das ist ja irgendwie quasi google
mit den ganzen informationen und alles
was über die menschen haben ein okay ich
nennen diese folge timo beck pizza den
ganzen tag dann gespannt auf den
geschmack jetzt hab ich euch im arm
wie geht es euch alles gut sei eine
komische position
seht euch mit dem lockdown schlecht
heute war aber auch echten bei team und
mir ist die geschichte mit der täterin
also für mich ist das eine texanerin
weil ich sie über täter kannte jetzt ein
crooner gestorben ist für mich ist für
uns beide war das eigentlich heute total
der schock das hat das noch mal so
richtig gezeigt wie das einfach jeden
erwischen kann und das ist pizza
live-streaming überall laufen kameras
die sie so gut aus
[Musik]
lecker ich bin jetzt ab sofort 24
stunden live ihr könnt mich bei allen
beobachten außer auf der toilette wie
fandest du den film wertung eigentlich
voll gut aber wurde immer schlechter
obwohl einer schwach angefangen stark
nachgelassen die 2
die idee war cool also dieses thema ich
mag ja vorher so nicht
utopie sondern so dass kopien irgendwie
na ja also ich fand auch das ende fand
ich es halt so abrupt geändert ich hasse
abrupte ende trotzdem volksmund wird
irgendwann selbst sein so ich werde
jetzt etwas neues einführen und zwar
habe ich gestern das zur timo gesagt
weil ich wieder mein handy ziemlich
lange in der hand hatte ich werde ab
sofort um 22 uhr das handy zur seite
legen und es wird nicht mehr handy zeit
geht dann auch keine rockfield mehr
ja und jetzt muss ich mich irgendwie
beschäftigen ohne handy und das wird
heute nicht mehr in die hand genommen
und ich wünsche euch einen wunderschönen
tag und wir machen jetzt schluss denn es
ist schluss für haitis
wir sehen uns morgen wieder
ich fühle mich wirklich überzeugen ist
ganz schön gruselig und ich und sowie
pizza gegessen team gemacht viel zu
leckere pizza